hello everybody hope that you're good
that's an interesting start of the week
I mean we were expecting a Monday false
move but this is something else I mean
we were expecting 62,500 and we've
actually dropped to
61,000 that's a big difference we've
gone from the this 4our uh time frame
liquidity pull that it was basically
here okay valuable there you can see
62,500 he also match with the
liquidation hit map in the one month
time frame we could see a clu of
liquidations there um if you read the
Bitcoin soon the update last night on X
um we've actually continued dropping
right now during this well at the start
of the London session the European
session and we've actually drop to the
range lows now in the range lows it's
true that we should find some strong
support because if you notice here h on
why is that purple let me change that to
White like that so you can see better
you can see there also in this area in
this area so why not maybe we find
support here too all right um we've had
a very fast drop in the last uh two to 3
weeks um imagine how the market is right
now like um I imagine that anybody
holding a short position is very
comfortable and probably calling for
lower
prices and that's why we want to go in a
moment into high block Capital we're
want to check the liquidation levels but
um that's why yesterday I was calling
the possibility of a sort of squeeze
during this week with the possibility
again of a m this false move to the
downside first so um I imagine that
there are many traders in shorts that
feel
comfortable and in the other hand there
are a bunch of traders that want to open
Longs but they are too scared or they
don't see it clear to to click the buy
button so when we have that type of
environment in the in the retail Trader
a lot of shorts feeling comfortable and
and quite euphoric about it and then you
have another group of traders that want
to open long but they are too scared
because the market keeps moving down
that's when you usually see a short
squeeze and I'm not saying that it's
going to happen I'm all I'm saying is
that it's possible and it's likely that
it does so it's something we have to get
prepared for because um short squeezes
or long squeezes are impulsive moves
that but it's basically a very fast move
that um leaves everybody behind so
if you are in a if you are in a position
of a profit then you can see it wiping
out or fading away those profits very
quickly okay and even turn into losses
so um it's something definitely to keep
an eye for because when they happen they
happen very aggressively so anytime that
I see a possibility of a sorty squeeze I
like to call it because um I think it's
something worth to keep an eye on okay
so right now range lows Monday's false
move look at look at at the speed of
this move okay you can see that it's
been very violent this is from Sunday
night okay all of this drop it's been
maybe like a 10% drop no 8% drop perhaps
5% drop I've got a bit too too excited
there 5% drop in how many hours is this
literally in in 12 16 hours that is very
fast okay that's a very fast drop at the
start of the week and if something if
there is something common across the
false moves
especially at the start of the week is
that they are very quick so duing by the
speed of this move to the downside here
of this drop here then um yes um it's
very likely that that's a false move
basically okay um of course we're going
to have some invalidations those
invalidations are going to be very clear
what are the range lows so if we start
to see Bitcoin
losing the range lows or even
consolidating below them that's going to
tell you that it's likely that was a
continuation to the downside okay and
that short of squeeze would be H
invalidated but given the chart right
now for what I see right now it's more
likely that we see some kind of a short
squeeze and a short squeeze don't get me
wrong a short squeeze is not this okay
that is not short squeeze cuz that would
be another wave a leg up different okay
a short squee is something like this
kind of like a V shape or or yeah like a
vshape uh structure if you want to call
it like that okay so we want to go now
into h capital we're want to see uh what
levels are interesting as a target for
that sort of squeeze we're want to check
the liquidation levels and something
that I also want to mention is that to
me the way that I'm trading this is
basically I looking for Longs rather
than shorts okay when price has been
dropping like this and I see the
possibility of a short swi I don't want
to open more shorts so all that I'm
looking now is to open Longs when do I
think it's again no Financial advice
when do I think it's a good moment for
me to open along well basically if we go
into the New York session that's in 4
hours from here well from I upload the
vide be maybe 3 hours or 2 hours and a
half If We Hold above the range lows
that is telling me that yes there might
be intentions to hold the range lows and
do the short squee here okay and
probably would take you to 64k something
like that but let's go to liquidation
levels they go to High L capital and
we're going to be able to see the
targets there more clear first of all
liquidation hit Maps let's have a look
at this while in the 70s time frame I
don't really see anything interesting
here nah nothing interesting let's check
the one month time frame this is going
to be
interesting because this is a chart that
I posted yesterday in the bitco date and
you can see how here
we had a cluster of liquidations at
62,500 now it's true that we swept those
lows all the way to
61,000 and
now could we drop low I mean I don't
really see more liquidity down here okay
at least for now so um I think that the
range lows are more likely to hold at
least in the short term that's what I
think okay and in the 3 month time frame
this Al this is also quite an
interesting chart because it basically
give us two Targets one to the upside
one to the downside come on you can see
this very clear Target to the downside
55,800 Target to the upside
73,800 okay so the question is what is
going to happen first okay and uh to me
that question gets answered by whether
if we're going to be able to hold the
range lows or not cuz obviously if we
don't hold the range lows then yes
continuation to the downside 55,800 is
next but as long as we hold the range
lows and we are in
this sideways move in this range is like
a sideways move after a impulsive move
up then it's true that could be some
accumulation or consolidation before the
next move up so um that could take us to
73,000 okay so um as of right now as
long as we hold inside well above the
range lows no fear I have no fear for
56,000 okay once or if we drop below the
range lows then of course that's going
to signal that the next Target is here
all right and now if we go into the
liquidation
levels I'm trying to be as fast as
possible to not make the video too long
um because I'm remaking it because I I
filmed it but uh unfortunately I didn't
have a in it uh so I'm I'm doing again
but no problem this these are the
liquidation levels and wow it's little
bit more interesting now I can see more
spikes but first of all the Delta what
is the Delta telling us the Delta St
knows that there is let me check $16
billion worth of sh liquidations of
course take this amount with a pinch of
salt you've seen me um using the max
liquidity setting so these numbers are
not correct but I'm using them because
I'm used to them because I've been using
them for years so I know when this is H
when this is low based on the number
okay but again it doesn't mean that
there are $15 million of course that's
not the case but yeah it's true that
there is going to be a lot of
liquidations to the upside from short
positions and that's what the Delta is
train you can see continue increasing
increasing increasing increasing and
that's one is telling you risk of a
short squeeze coming okay now if we
check the spikes to the right you're
want to see well we have a few spikes
here I'm not going to lie to you so um
um oh you SE it there 61,500
then you got another
one uh it's difficult to cut them
sometimes there 62,200 but then the ones
I was paying more attention to are this
okay you have one interesting one here
at
63,500 and of course pay attention to
this one
64,800 and 66,1 15 and those two are the
largest ones okay all the way to
66,000 but the longest
one as well as that one is at 64,800 so
in my opinion the short squeeze Target
area goes to 64,8 75 and it goes as high
but I doubt will get all the way here if
it happens
66150 okay I thought we get will
together basically because these are
short liquidations and of course when
they start to see price going up and
reversing if that's the case and that
happens then they are going to close
this positions here and this amount is
going to get banished is going to get
fading get faded away okay it's going to
disappear so yeah I think that 64,8 75
is probably the highest it can go okay
and that's maybe around another 5% up
perhaps I think so yep that's going to
be quite an interesting uh thing to to
keep an eye on for okay so um that's
pretty much everything that I want to
say guys now again my plan is wait for
New York session see if we hold above
the range slows if that is the case then
I'm going to open a long hoping that
this is a mon this false move because
it's been a fast move down risk of a
sort of squeeze there were liquidations
below it we've tested the range lows it
seems like a perfect scenario for mly
first move before a short squeeze so if
we are able to hold above the range lows
um enter into New York then yes it's
probably going to be a very interesting
two days ahead Tuesday Wednesday perhaps
even Thursday although on Thursday we
could see a reversal it's going to be
quite interesting to see some upside
momentum if that's the case again I'm I
being correct maybe we lose the range
lows and if that's the case then all
this idea gets invalidated that is not s
to squeeze and we continue dropping
lower so um tell me what you think guys
um quite interesting see now your charts
as I enj seeing your charts so if you
have any chart then tag me on Twitter on
telegram whatever you want I appreciate
it so um that's everything guys thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you soon